[Musique]
mes amis de la vie si tous quand est
astucieux belle peine
la plus jolie
le plus sérieux est devenu un ami quand
il a vu comme gens du haut qui ondule
admirablement ça va bien fabrice s'en va
très bien et toi ça va je te dis bonjour
bonjour bonjour tout le monde
bonjour à tous tu vois regarde cette
feuille que tu as devant toi oui un non
pas celle là bas c'est celle-là oui
celle-là tu veux je la veux ça nous a
seul la jetée parce que c'est celle là
tu vois c'est moi je vais la montrer à
nos amis regard voilà il ya deux trapèze
il y a effectivement de trapèze deux
figures géométriques que l'on appelle
des trappes et voilà bon c'est pas pour
se suspendre nice balance et non pas du
tout mais lequel est le plus grand comme
ça le miel est le plus grand des jeux au
moi je dirais celui là me paraît le plus
grand bien je vais donner passage donner
une réglette prix d'allemagne règle est
épais voile partie du fait attenti tous
à temps je suis en train de chercher de
gimmicks tétouan qui tout est toi alors
lequel des deux est le plus grand et ben
moi j'ai dit le plus grand c'est celui
là eh bien pas du tout mon semblable à
tant va regarder
voilà mesure et celui du haut
approximativement sur lanouf est en bas
16 cm exactement ça ja je ne sais pas si
vous le voyez bien oui ça devrait aller
à peu près et celui là a biffé également
16 cm c'est incroyable ça si les ans aux
attentes en hausse est important casey
pareil 0 11 0 on sait ça 11 cm en fit un
effet gentil absolument un effet
d'optique
alors maintenant vas tu cherches est
organisée pour mon panier d'accord pour
tout dit ou fait coucher un nid à paix
alors tu connais monnier je lui
mot-à-mot sa mère c'est le jeu du mot
d'amour jean rappelle brièvement la
règle avec des cartons que nous allons
extraire de ce panier
nous aurons des
et des fissures des objets des
personnages des animaux qui représente
des syllabes et avec ses syllabes
nous formerons d'autres mots nous avions
déjà fait par exemple avec un phare un
mât de bateau et une si on avait fait
pharmacie c'est le même principe que
vous aurez appliqué aujourd'hui oui
c'est ça alors j'en prend combien
eh bien tu en prends tu en prends 5 pour
commencer 5
oui bon alors voilà j'en prends 5 et
puis tu va m'aider un toucan corps parce
que gvt dit oui mais le bel bien entendu
c'est certain alors je commence avec
ceux ci s'est tu je suppose que c'est
une hutte où je décore guise c'est une
lutte ça c'est un cochon un port à cet
apport dans le seau sports wii u des
ports voilà une port une peur
eric voruz tu as ça c'est un saint c'est
très particulier ça voyez vous ça c'est
à ce qu'on appelle un sion ainsi on oui
c'est ça le scion sci rennes c'est un
bout de cannes à pêche c'est à un
morceau de bois très flexible ah je ne
savais pas c'est un mot qu'on n'emploie
pas très souvent mais c'est ça existe un
sens
voilà pour le col seillier et enfin ça
c'est un saint oui mon dieu donne pas
brice oui ça y est j'ai trouvé quelqu'un
tu vas trouver quelque chose où ils
veulent quoi vie et bien tout simplement
port alors attends pas or ici on sait
qui fait portions assez bien joué ça
démange et même pas le temps de
réfléchir et tu as déjà trouver mention
voit la portion crois que ce sera
difficile de trouver
oui tempête ou qu'encore oui ça ça va
pas être comment écouter la alors et on
continue oui bien entendu l'idée toi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait accompli car tu
retires encore un petit carton oui parce
que là on a plus assez de hausse il est
trop facile alors si on en tire encore
un bien
normal c'est un tas attentats oui attend
un tas de sable mais pas de sabri
intérêts oui et ça c'est inspire toi
fabrice pas grand chose pour l'instant
alors qui rend correct à l'entretien 1 1
1 continue reprend reprend encore et
argent oui oui d'après ce qu'on ne peut
rien faire là qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est un chat ça assez d'achat un chat
miam miam à je me régale même avec sa
voix fait à temps mais ne servait pas de
mots - je vous préviens au quoi on va
trouver quelque chose pendant quelque
chose de très fort et on dit que tu
aurais dû trouver fabrice c'est bien la
clé intelligente pas trouvé voyons tu es
un mot de 4,6 la magie vous avez je
crains la portion de bell bell
si j'ai le droit le droit alors devant
jeu mais le chiffre 1
oui alors attends qu est ce que tu nous
prépares là tu vois avec le chiffre 1
oui alors au milieu je mets le temps oui
le tas et ça fait importations bien joué
par an si magnifique
résumons port tha si on voit le savez
vous ce que c'est que l'importation
c'est le fait d'importer des
marchandises d'un autre pays dans son
propre pays
si on achète une voiture d'un pays
voisin on importe cette voiture dans son
propre pays voilà importations bien
jouer être brave gars tu aurais vais
trouver ça arrive et il aurait dû jouer
leurs rideaux blancs tulle et harry oui
il faut que je l'écris paul écrit alors
un port à sion 4 si l'aca tu es très
fort je suis folle et pouvoir tirer la
carte
ah bravo oui là tu m'a impressionné
félicitations jeu très très très bien
arrive viens viens alegre tirer la carte
tu veux te dire une carte
oui tiens vas-y montre là moi avec
québec à celle là celle ci la wii bon
attends je vais la prendre
elles se sont
nos petits amis qui nous ont envoyé un
certain nombre de lettres et de cartes
ce dont nous les remercions vrai que
nous regardons tous ensemble courrier
très attentivement et cette carte vient
de nadine et shazia de quelque chose
comme ça qui habite angers alors je suis
sage dit elle à eux mêmes tant mieux
alors c'est un garçon d'ailleurs et je
suis un petit arabe
je veux que tout le monde soit heureux
ah c'était pour la nouvelle année comme
il est gentil je vous embrasse très fort
a new cb nous aussi et ben oui nous sur
lembras on t'embrasse et on pourrait
peut-être lui faire une surprise alors
on l'envoyait le le disque de la chanson
des capacités midi alors l'affairé fait
tu vas recevoir très bientôt le disque
des quatre amis voilà des côtés autant
d'ordinaire courues sur maps en temps tu
penses nous aussi on est content bon
allez je vous monsieur à fabrice oui
c'est à nous maintenant j'y vais bon
alors tu vas au tableau des marqueurs
comme d'habitude c'est très bien combien
de lettres
alors qu'on vient de l'être et bien
cette lettre oui je mène oui c'est cette
première lettre première lettre alors un
c1 c'est un c voilà cinq traits et pour
les lettres qui mac et la dernière
lettre 1 1 e
voilà alors qu'ici je te signale que
c'est toujours un moyen de plus bien sûr
celui ci retrace un mois je te veux dans
ses chaussures mais non inscrits dont
sans moyen de transport et ben oui
chaussures sans rien fait de sa vie face
et fabrice ont alors eu écoute
est ce que c'est un moyen de locomotion
dans les airs a non non non non sur des
rails
ah non non plus les sur la route banon
sur la route non non non non pas sur la
route sur la mer non sinon l'eau dans le
wydad ans lorsqu'elle mange dans la main
a pas spécialement sur la mer dans une
dans un flux une soif le we wish à flat
sur une rivière sur un petit ruisseau
c'est un set un bateau quand même et
c'est un sursaut un petit bateau tape
qui bat d'un petit bateau oh oui c'est
pas très grand une ou deux personnes
et oui oui peut-être maximum m avec des
rats est ce que je peux te quoi avec des
ran
oui enfin oui oui avec des amis mais je
peux te donner une lettre signée de jeu
1 la troisième
oui un troisième lettre c'est un y tu
vas y on y fait et c'est rare mais tu
vois un y
ah oui tu vois je vois pas justement ça
paraît bizarre ça ne va pas site
rallierait ce que tu as encore été
chercher avec ses lettres c'est rallye
ça commence par un c était bien certains
avec un y en troisième lettre oui oui
mais je ne penserai pas à caillac part à
zajac exactement avec un c est oui
pauvre pouces moussu à mais tout le
monde est en train de rire de trois
demandes rehab à landrin l'europe
entière s'esclaffe kayak kayak en fin de
séance avec un cac40 à huy y il ya quand
même un y à bras car il ya un y
oh là là voilà kayak du tout du tout
l'écrivain y ainsi jelmi misère mon
pauvre pouces ou en tout cas moi je fais
de poser une question qu est ce que tu
sais qui a inventé le kayak a peut-être
les indiens non les eskimos al ces silos
et je suis fabriqué avec des peaux et il
s'en servait pour chasser le phoque
tu vois à j'en ai quand même appris une
chose oui c'est vrai bravo à me bien
nous retrouvions bell bell à oui on va
retrouvé bailbé alors annoncé
là ce n'est pas vous c'est ce que j'ai
fait si la musique tu vas y toi c'est
[Musique]
bon pour les enfants
fabrice oui 18 avec moi notre petit jeu
musical je suis prêt belle gueule voilà
gvt raconter une petite histoire dans
laquelle je ne dirais pas les mots en
entier et tu devras les remplacer à
l'aide d'une note de musique que tu
placera sur cette portée musicale et la
fan tu verras que toutes ces notes te
donneront les premières mesures d'une
chanson pop
alors aujourd'hui oh mon dieu qu'est ce
que j'ai dit aujourd'hui t'as vu si
c'est bien parler mais ce fait la
chanson dont je parle exprime un jeu un
jeu auquel on joue à l'école du sommet
en cercle au lieu de la cour en or au
milieu c'est sa planète la note me voilà
autrement dit ces lampes istanbul lui
des montages mépris cambrai allons
voyons oui et puis rapidos tu ne souffle
pas les notes à fabrice alors ça se
passe donc pendant la récréation entre
un cours de géographie et un cours de
latin là que le siaap très bien formés
tout le monde mais les mains devant soi
et le chef du judo n'a ni eau un signal
rapide aux sétois
à ce moment là on fait passer quelque
chose à son voisin on prend un petit
objet par exemple nano de riz de 2,1 à
nos de riz un anneau de rideau au parc
de rhinau de ria jouèrent au milieu du
cercle kystique de savoir où elano
évidemment personne ne l'aide tu penses
au contraire ou ne fais pas de gestes ou
ne dit pas un mot qui serait une
indication
et surtout on ne fait pas de grimaces
mie de pain
mag avec o2 simagrées c'est un jeu pour
lequel il faut être très sérieux au pas
comme moi comme pour tous les jeux
d'ailleurs il faut être sérieux il faut
de l'ordre et le de l'adie clean simple
in pahlavi sait plus bien sûr ceux qui
ont envie de remuer de s'agiter il vaut
mieux qu'il joue à autre chose aux
gendarmes et aux voleurs ou bien qu'ils
organisent des rondes hall descoings bis
road hole des farandoles à sa fin voila
voila trouver vivres à lenox hill a
chance on me l'a sido 6 6 face à samedi
quelque chose ça à ton âge je me
concentre et je les nazis
la semaine
je me tais
le furet du vagin
il courait pour le choix passés par ici
il repassera par là dit ou tu devrais
chanter avec nous vous avez tué le pape
est suivie mais je pense qu'il ne va pas
tarder vient tout à l'heure c'était bien
vers une petite bise à tout bonus en
plus en vain il faut pas chercher son
peuple est-ce qu'il faut qu'on change et
ils savent déjà papa d'amy d'état qui
fait que la vie s'est désisté et rzeszow
fait des choses mais comme juni pas de
mine war livrons à faire attention les
capitales ne sont pas décents rudy et
axa sont heureux car ils aiment la vie
mais
[Musique]
mais non
mais n'avait pas joué aujourd'hui et
amis de vouloir devenir amis
e
[Musique]
oui tu vois tu